know the details know the philosophy and
don't worry about all the Myesha in the
middle the politics the process that all
the crap does not matter that's it I
spent all my time the clouds in a Turk
mindset of execution clouds clouds and
Dolly three years old my grandfather
took me to Swan Lake I was so mesmerized
by the lead Swan they always had that
image in my head I want to be that fairy
tale there's no perfect way to do ballet
but you're striving towards perfection
six days a week on Sundays it's my only
day off still I find the time to work
out you have to have is such an intense
dedication passion my dirt is the pain
the exhaustion how do i improve my spin
faster jump higher how do i improve my
point my extension my foot tha is the
only way to truly be obsessed with
anything is to love it
don't waste time chase what you love
yo what'd you think of these new clouds
and dirt kicks you have one life
you will die I've realized what's going
on here
one life everybody's doubting themselves
instead of thinking about what do I have
and so everybody just think about what
they're not instead of utilizing the
place all everybody is the happiest when
they get to do what they want to be
doing when you get to doing what you
want
and so I'm acting that way I'm acting
that way what's the best way to be in
this video not watching it live in the
clouds and the dirt
[Music]